he is the head coach of the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers here on the Rich Eisen show
he is Bruce Arians how how's the coach
of Tom Brady doing
I say he's doing extremely well right
now and hopefully everybody out there is
healthy and safe yeah I bet exactly
that's the most important thing before
we get into that I mean how are you
handling yourself with coronavirus
obviously coach with you in a yeah we we
shut down the office you know the other
day and then I've been very fortunate my
daughters flew in with my three-year-old
one year old grandson so they are
wearing me out
oh my gosh
so you you're you're in your house with
how many how many human beings are in
constant yeah well my my wife my
daughter her husband and two wild
Indians the little rascals three and one
and they're both walking and running so
I'm having a big time yeah you're having
a flashback huh little flashback right
now - yep indeed okay so then let's get
into let's get into the football aspect
of things here and Tom bright I mean if
I had told you that you'd be the head
coach of Tom Brady at some point in your
career what would you said to that coach
when did I die and and how did I get
back no way I mean never did I think
that he would ever leave New England and
you know this year he kind of got a
feeling maybe so you do your due
diligence as an organization and you
rate all the quarterbacks that might
become available we had him ranked
number one if it happened we would make
a concerted effort and we did so walk me
through because I'm reading reporting
here but is it is it really the case you
did not lift a phone and talk to Tom
Brady until Wednesday did the actual new
league year hey is that the first time
you spoke to him about joining the
Buccaneers personally yes I mean that
was you know the Jason that talked with
his representatives in the legal
tampering period and we had to wait
until Wednesday evening I think was when
his evening and had a long conversation
and everything went well everything
worked out so I was as shocked as
everybody else so walk me through what
was the conversation with Tom like when
you when you first connected with him
and started talking to him about the
Tampa Bay Buccaneers and joining your
team was that like
but just didn't know each other look
that you know and I did a couple games
for CBS so I was in production meetings
with Tom so I knew in that way but just
talk offensive philosophy family
relocations all those types of things
how great it is down here to live and
you know the organization we have great
ownership and fantastic facility and you
know then we start talking about
football and and how they fit and I
think what he brings to us more than
anything is a proven leader leader of
men that knows how to win championships
and you know we've got a really good
young football team that needs a leader
like that so what do you say because
obviously there's a lot of downtime for
a lot of people to suppose these things
and as it was leading up to the legal
tampering window I guess or the legal
conversation window is that Brady at age
entering age 43 and an offense like
yours no risk it no biscuit pushing it
down the field potentially sending
everybody out and routes is not actually
a system fit what do you say to that
Bruce I think they didn't watch the tape
and you know he can make every thrill of
still but he throws the guys open you
know we don't throw it deep every with
those guys open we we share very very
similar philosophies the way they run
the ball the way we run the ball
play-action do those things the empty
formations get it out quick but if
there's a deep matchup in a short pass
take the deep batch up you don't hold it
any longer but you know just throw it to
the guys that's open and that's what
he's always done so I think he's a
perfect fit so when what
what does the often snowing to look like
because I'm sure he wants to have some
sort of say as to what he likes dislikes
wants to maybe have well I think that
that was a big part of you know my my
philosophy has always been great
collaboration with the quarterback no
matter who it's been you know it's our
it's the offense of the Buccaneers he's
going to come anything to learn the
terminology he's all in I can't wait to
get started
will steal some ideas from him you know
man whether it be third down red zone
what his favorite stuff is I'm sure it's
in our offense already you know watching
their tape very very similar stuff so
yeah it's just great that I love
collaborating with great minds and
that's one of the greatest minds ever
did he lift the phone based you can tell
or maybe you did to Peyton Manning and
have a conversation with him about you
and vice versa not not not today I did
not and I did not do not think he did
off either but wouldn't be surprised
because they are good friends yeah I
know and and it's just uh I got I can
wrap my arms around the fact that he's
not a New England anymore and he chose
you guys and not just because of the
fact that he's not a New England anymore
you know the fact that he's with you is
just an amazing combination that I'm
wondering if you even wrapped your arms
around that or mind around it yet
yourself Bruce yeah I do every day I'll
sleep much that just can't wait to get
started you know hopefully hopefully in
our country can kick this viruses ass
and get back to going and we can get
into a some form of a spring football
philosophy of when we're gonna practice
and how it's gonna work out and get all
that settled so that we can get started
you know we'll get him up to speed as
fast as we can and I'm sure he's already
reached out to some of our guys about
when we're gonna work out together
somewhere else meantime so let's just uh
in the few minutes we have left here
with you sir Bruce Arians here on the
Rich Eisen show I'm in my office Bruce
is down there and Tampa we're all social
distancing properly
conversation so the Jamis of it all what
would you tell a team that knocks on the
door maybe to you about Jameis if
they're interested in his services what
would you tell them
bruising yeah I've called I've called a
couple of teams that you're gonna get
one of the hardest workers you've ever
had and a great young man you know it
didn't work out for us
only because Tom Brady was available and
and we had a teddy bridgewater if that
would have worked out it's not we were
going full steam ahead back with Jameis
he's a great young man and nobody's
gonna outwork him so you've you've
lifted the phone yourself to call people
I did I talked to two teams you did and
I don't know if you're willing to I'm
sure you're not willing to tell which
teams they are but yeah I'd like to keep
that one to myself but what what do you
sense the level of interest is for him
as it started uh no I think it was just
just to get him on your roster and and
it would be a great fit and one team was
not interested in the other would they
thank you for calling okay and you know
I cuz did you know I was there week 16
mid the game and Jameis did come off the
ridiculous hot streak for a month and
then we pick sixes and the Bugaboos
returning both games you were in I mean
it really was amazing so what would you
say what at the end of the day is
something that just did not work out
click anything of that regard
Bruce yeah I think it was that
regression in those last two ballgames
after he made such good progress you
know you don't throw pretty 130
touchdowns and not having a talent I
mean amazing those numbers are amazing
themselves those turnovers and December
made us look and see if was there
something better behind door number two
we own that we owe that to our horse and
our rest of our football team to see not
thinking as Gumby Tom Brady right okay
so before I let you go
Oh what what else does Tampa need to do
now that you got Tom obviously the
windows there your windows there it's
it's now 2 to the next 2 to 3 years
there's eggs in the tv12 basket we all
know that what needs to be done you do
you think to get this team on Super Bowl
okay would you know we've got a couple
more guys to sign defensively hopefully
I have a great draft and and get him
ready to play
how much is your favor we were so close
last year never 9 doesn't sound close
but you eliminate 20 turnovers and we're
in there no I'm in the schedule last
year I mean I personally witnessed some
of your schedule out there in London and
then to see yeah Tennessee you went a
month and a half without being home I
mean and then yeah yeah it was crazy
exactly so when it all comes down to it
I mean do you think you've got yourself
a Super Bowl team to put it right there
and in Raymond James for for the first
time a home team being the true home
team in a Super Bowl do you think you
got that well I think I think our
players believe it defensively we need
another piece to come back and then yeah
I think we have a chance to win our
division and get into the playoffs so
once you're in the playoffs you know we
we want it as a six seed we want to know
as a first seed in the past and so it's
just getting into the dance I think yes
we can get in the dance okay and when
did you realize I think Tom's coming us
when did was there a moment where you
had a Congress in exchange with him
anything
yeah when we when I hung up that when I
hung up the phone that night I talked to
Jason I said I think he's coming
what gave you that impression just
everything his enthusiasm a because he
was trying to sell me as much as I was
trying to sell him no kidding Jason he
was his excitement level was off the
charts I mean I was I couldn't wait to
go to practice and then telling people
and your family telling kids I imagine
Tom Brady's coming that had to be a
conversation for you
yeah yeah you know they knew about time
everybody else knew but it was still a
bit surreal okay and did you go over
with him stuff about his lives
maybe his trainer coming in and bringing
all that into the fold what makes him
comfortable is he gonna have a lot of
say on that front
coach oh yeah yeah one thing I believe
in is guys each guy has something
different you know Duncan sue has some
things and worked with him and just
whatever it takes for you to get ready
to play on Sunday I'm all for okay maybe
you can be do do the T at T b12 system
if you ever had an avocado ice cream Iko
no I'm not that's to California for me
brother you the man Bruce stay safe stay
healthy very literate Congrats on
getting I mean look you you you you've
coached Peyton Manning Tom Brady I don't
know who else has really done that quite
frankly you're you're a unicorn you're
an old exactly one two
I will never forget that alright um be
well be healthy and be healthy be safe
and obviously and enjoy having those
grandkids around enjoy it do to your to
my man that's right here on the Rich
Eisen show thanks coach